President Trump is meeting with Italy's
leaders this morning after his highly
anticipated visit with Pope Francis at
the Vatican their private half hour
meeting began with a handshake
the president and the Pope put aside
their previous clashes to send a message
of peace Margaret Brennan is traveling
with the president in Rome Margaret good
morning good morning well the Holy See
visit caps president Trump's tour of the
capitals of the three great monotheistic
religion every president since
Eisenhower has gotten a private audience
with the Holy Father but Pope Francis
and president Trump are too unique and
starkly different leaders Swiss Guard
saluted President Trump and the first
lady as they arrived for a face-to-face
meeting with Pope Francis at the
Apostolic Palace mr. Trump introduced
his sizeable entourage including
daughter Ivanka and son-in-law Jared
Krishna the polite papal encounter was a
sharp contrast to their clashes during
the campaign for a religious leader to
question a person's faith is disgraceful
when asked about the border wall
proposal Pope Francis said it is not
Christian to build walls instead of
bridges mr. Trump fired back I don't
like fighting with the Pope actually I
don't think this is a fight the two
leaders also have diametrically opposed
views on many issues we will suspend the
Syrian refugee program president Trump
tried to ban Syrian refugees
while Pope Francis personally took in 12
Muslims who had washed up on Greek
shores to Rome on his papal plane when
asked about their upcoming meeting Pope
Francis said quote open up at a sauna I
never make a judgement about a person
without listening to them after today's
30-minute closed-door meeting the Pope
appeared to give a gentle nudge to
change the president's mind on climate
change which mr. Trump has previously
called a hopes presenting him with three
books including one he described as
focusing on care of our common home the
environment mr. Trump gifted him a
custom bound set of the writings of dr.
Martin Luther King jr. on his way out
President Trump told the Pope that he'd
never forget what he told him then the
president and the first lady went on a
private tour of the Sistine Chapel Nora
the president heads next to a NATO
meeting in Brussels later today
Thank You Margot Brennan there in st.
Peter's Square